like at the talking stage a girl  coming up with like so what are we or  where's this guy in like a couple months  in I think that's doing too much  wait no well I disagree with her okay  okay depends how many marks in so how  many months  like um for me I've always said like  four seasons on the road trip  Four Seasons and a road trip yeah that's  how that's how long you kind of need to  that's not that's how long you that's  how long you need to kind of know  someone you know so you talk to a girl  you you do like the situationship thing  for a year if it's going to be a  situationship  um then yeah for a year before you kind  of decide whether you want to lock it  down or not